Ben & Jerry’s was originally going to be
a bagel company.
Ben Cohen and Jerry Greenfield ended up changing
their minds when they found out how much it
would cost to get all the needed equipment
for making bagels.
Instead, in 1978, they both took a $5 correspondence
course from Pennsylvania State University
on ice cream making.
They then used $12,000, $4000 of which was
borrowed, and converted an old gas station
in Burlington, Vermont into an ice cream parlor
called Ben & Jerry’s Homemade.
Before opening the ice cream shop, Jerry Greenfield
was a lab technician, in New York, who tried
three times to get into medical school, failing
each time.
Ben Cohen attended various colleges and eventually
dropped out and settled on working as a crafts
teacher for emotionally disturbed children
in New York.
In New York, Ben and his old friend from Jr.
High and High school, Jerry Greenfield, shared
an apartment in Manhattan before once again
parting ways.
Eventually, the two reunited and deciding
to start some sort of a food company, first
going with bagels but then settling on ice
cream.
When they sought out a suitable location for
their ice cream shop, they set the criteria
that it should be some place with a very warm
climate; should be a college town; and should
be a town where there were no other ice cream
shops.
In the end, they found that every college
town in a warm climate already had one or
more ice cream shops, so they threw out the
warm-requirement and settled on Burlington,
Vermont, which didn’t have an ice-cream
shop.
By 1983, just five years after they first
opened their doors, Ben & Jerry’s products,
at their own retail stores and sold through
various other outlets, had gross sales of
around $2 million.
Just one year later, they achieved a gross
of over $4 million.
One year after that, they were grossing $9
million.
One year after that, in 1986, they grossed
over $20 million.
In 1987, they finally broke their amazing
“doubling” streak and only grossed $32
million.
The following year, their rapid growth caused
President Ronald Reagan to award the two the
“U.S.
Small Business Persons of the Year”.
In April of 2000, a mere 22 years after Ben
& Jerry’s Homemade Inc. was founded, the
two sold the now publicly traded company for
$326 million to the British-Dutch food company
Unilever.
At the time, annual sales were just shy of
$200 million and today sits at around $240
million.
Bonus Facts:
• Since their inception, Ben & Jerry’s
ice cream was touted as “all natural”.
However, in 2010, the company was forced to
stop labeling their ice cream and frozen yogurt
such when it was discovered by the Center
for the Science in Public Interest that corn
syrup and many other artificial ingredients
were used to make their ice cream.
• Contrary to rumor, Ben and Jerry do not
appear to have ever been a couple.
In fact, Jerry was dating his eventual wife
when Ben & Jerry were roommates.
He also left the company for a few years to
help his future wife, Elizabeth, pursue her
Ph.D. in psychology.
The rumor that Ben and Jerry are gay received
a huge boost when Ben & Jerry’s came out
with the “Hubby Hubby” flavor for one
month, which featured two men getting married
on the cover and was in support of gay marriage
rights.